mes ancêtres ont été volés à la mère
Afrique en l'an 1619 le premier
navire négrier et ont amené Jamestown Virginia
la première personne qui est morte dans la première
guerre américaine la révolution américaine
c'était un homme noir son nom est Crispus
Attucks beaucoup de gens ne le font pas  sachez que l'
histoire et cela prouve que les
Noirs meurent pour ce
pays et que nous n'avons toujours pas tous les pleins
droits chaque guerre que nous avons pulpitis country
black GI est-il juste de servir plus que
les larges Américains qui vous ont envoyé ici
ce film s'adresse joyeusement aujourd'hui dans
les rues
[Musique]
J'ai vu tellement de jeunes jeunes enfants avec des
parents tenant leurs parents par la main ou
prenant une décision que leurs enfants ont
besoin de voir ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis en Amérique et ils veulent que
leur  les enfants à être témoins et
ils expliquent qu'ils ne font pas que
sortir en même temps
que vous gagnez une éducation se produisent parce que
les enfants disent à maman papa ce qui se
passe et ces parents un
expliquant à leurs très jeunes enfants
ce qui se passe pourquoi ils sont là-bas
et pourquoi ils les ont amenés aussi et
ce que je pense est plus d'espoir que le
grand nombre de mes jeunes frères
et sœurs blancs qui se joignaient à nous
rejoignent leur  sœurs noires et brunes, vous
savez que c'est vraiment une
mosaïque, il n'y avait pas que des noirs noirs et
bruns qui défilaient et dans de
nombreuses villes, vous savez que les noirs
bruns sont la minorité
[Musique]
le meurtre fictif de radar campbell
était basé  sur le vrai meurtrier
artiste maladroit Michael Stewart puis j'ai
écrit la grande route faire la bonne chose en
1989 8088 caméra 89 et dîner puis plusieurs
années plus tard je vois Eric Gardner maintenant plus
récemment King Floyd donc c'est triste